hello everyone welcome to the March
edition of ask me anything for the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll and this as you probably know is
the first version of the AMAs where the
answer is this episode that we're
listening to right now is going to be
released publicly we haven't exactly
figured out the best way to get it to
the public so for right now it's just
gonna be the usual thing where I put it
on the patreon page and I'm just gonna
let it be accessible to the public most
people won't know it because they don't
visit the patreon page but I will let
people know by Twitter or whatever when
we eventually get a different system
running if that ever happens the patreon
supporters method is not gonna change in
any way you'll still get the episodes
more or less as soon as they're recorded
more or less right here on the patreon
page no ads for anything like that don't
worry about it just so you know that
whatever questions you ask the answers I
give will be sent out there to the world
for everyone to listen to apologies that
this is coming out a little bit later
than usual this is Sunday March 8th when
I'm recording this and releasing it of
course I was in Australia did a very fun
tour through Australia New Zealand
sponsored by an organization called
think Inc which is a wonderful little
tiny organization that sends speakers
dealing with fun intellectual topics
around Australia New Zealand they're
hoping to expand their purview to LA and
California and elsewhere so maybe you'll
see them if you're in one of those areas
soon it was interesting when I flew into
Australia of course people are careful
now because we're fighting a virus
possible pandemic the corona virus and
its associated infection kovat 19 and
the disease whose name I forget the
nomenclature is all complicated but we
all know what we mean when you fly into
New Zealand or Australia they take this
very seriously there are questionnaires
saying have you been to mainland China
in the last 14 days are you coughing do
you have any symptoms of serious illness
when you fly back to the United States
you says welcome back is really nothing
at all that happens usually I'm not in
favor of
panicking or overreacting to things like
this but for those of us here in the
u.s. I think that this is a situation
where a little bit of reaction is
absolutely called for in some sense it's
a disease that that has a low fatality
rate but it's a new disease we have no
vaccine or cure for and even a low
fatality rate if many many people get it
is a terrible thing you know I've read
credible estimates that the number of
people in the world that will be
infected by the virus is between 40% and
70% of the total world's population so
in a very real sense you will probably
be infected by this virus now you can
get infected and not get sick and you
can get sick and not die especially if
you're not already fighting with
respiratory problems or elderly or frail
or whatever but still this is something
I think makes perfect sense to worry
about
I've already had several events that I
was supposed to participate in be
canceled many of you might know the
March American Physical Society meeting
was cancelled literally the day before
people were helping on their planes and
I think I get it I'm in favor of that I
think that if you can avoid unnecessary
air travel if you can avoid being in
large groups of people especially people
groups that are coming from all over the
world in various different places I
certainly don't trust our current
governmental set up here in the United
States to do the right thing they seem
to be much more interested in keeping
the reported numbers down than keeping
the actual amount of infection low and
dealing with it they're not testing
nearly as much as we could so it makes
sense to take some precautions by
yourself what which of course includes
more than anything else
washing your hands right washing your
hands and not going into danger zones
are the two most obvious things that you
can sensibly do but you know you don't
need to completely cancel your life you
don't need to bunker down I think that
even domestic air travel for non huge
conference reasons is probably perfectly
legitimate although what do I know I'm a
physicist with the cat on his head in
his Twitter bio not a professional
biologist or epidemiologist with that I
think that we're ready to go some good
questions this month so let's go
[Music]
first question is from valkia who says
in your talk at UBC from December you
mentioned that in the universe with
emergent time and a finite dimensional
hilbert space the number of possible
states is finite and so the universe
must have a beginning and an end isn't
it also possible that such a universe
there in such a universe there could be
a closed loop of quantum states of some
sort yeah I think that's completely
possible I'm not even sure the
difference is to be perfectly honest
there in in one of these universes what
we're imagining here is that quantum
mechanics is living in a finite
dimensional space of possibilities so as
I will say I think later on in the in
the AMA there's always an infinite
number of quantum states in any Hilbert
space but the number of distinct quantum
states the number of quantum states with
no overlap with each other is a finite
number in a finite dimensional hilbert
space and the idea of emergent time in
these models is that time is a label on
the quantum states with that is told by
a clock that lives within the quantum
states so really when you have these
emergent time models with a finite
dimensional hilbert space there's only a
finite number of possible ticks of the
clock because there are a finite number
of distinct quantum states for the clock
to have but time is emerging in these
models so whether or not you think of
the evolution as starting somewhere and
ending somewhere versus going in a loop
is kind of hard to distinguish what you
mean right I mean I think you can think
of it in either way because time is not
fundamental time is a way of thinking
about interpreting these labels on the
quantum states Demetriou Shevchenko says
do you think logical absolutes the laws
of logic law of excluded middle stuff
like that are emergent rather than
intrinsic to the universe could they be
emergent from the wave function of the
universe and the Schrodinger equation
this is you know one of those subtle
questions I don't have a strong feeling
about this Damita Demetriou this is a
question that relates to issues of
mathematical Platonism
in my mind so platonism is the idea that
the mathematical structures are real in
some sense my inclination
is to not go that way to not think of
mathematical constructs as real to think
of the physical world as real whatever
you whatever your attitude about this is
but I don't I don't feel strongly about
it which is why I'm sort of speaking
hesitatingly like I've heard good
arguments on either way and I don't have
a settled opinion my own whatever it is
whatever the reality level of a
mathematical structure is or a law of
logic it's a different kind of reality
than tables and chairs or electrons or
something like that but I also don't
think that they're emergent laws of
mathematics and laws of logic I think
that their descriptions you know their
descriptions that you that you can't
avoid I think that's the difference that
I would want to emphasize here the laws
of physics being emergent while the the
higher-level laws of physics that are
emergent like fluid mechanics for fluids
for example are contingent in the sense
that in a different universe you would
have had different laws of physics I
don't think that the laws of logic or
mathematics would be different in a
different universe
they might not describe the universe but
I think that's a different thing the
laws of logic are the laws of logic they
follow from axioms to conclusions and
from different axioms you get two
different conclusions
that's what math and logic do what
science does trying to figure out which
patterns actually describe our real
contingent universe is a different thing
so they're not emergent in the same way
just like they might not be real in the
same way crabby smiles says on the last
AMA you state the broken egg I've edited
this a little bit just for length but I
think I got the essence correct on the
last AMA you state the broken egg on the
sidewalk is a record of a prior event
but only if we assume a low entropy
boundary condition have you considered
that a low entropy boundary condition
may be part of what causal explanation
is what I mean is the causal explanation
always consists in finding a compact
parsimonious description in terms of a
combination of dynamic laws and boundary
conditions the most compact description
of any present macro state includes a
low entropy boundary condition which
thus becomes the past this is because
lower entropy macro states are also of
lower algorithmic information content if
we derive a thermodynamic arrow in this
way from parsimony
we cannot also ask for an explanation of
the low entropy early universe indeed
how could we justify any such
theoretical explanation except by appeal
to its parsimony so I don't exactly
agree with that I think that you know
there's some correct things going on
here but I think that I think about it a
little bit differently so
parenthetically one thing to get clear
you say because lower entropy macro
states are of also lower algorithmic
information content that's certainly not
true as a general rule the lowest
algorithmic information content is in
the highest entropy macro state right
the highest entropy macro state is
thermal equilibrium it has essentially
zero algorithmic information content you
just say boom thermal equilibrium but
likewise some very very low entropy
macro states also have low algorithmic
information content you say you know all
the gas is on one side of the box or
something like that there is no simple
monotonic relationship between entropy
and algorithmic information content so
that's one parenthetical remark but the
other one is you say the most compact
description of any present macro state
includes a low entropy boundary
condition which thus becomes the past
and I don't really agree with that one
either if you have a compact if you have
a description of the present macro state
that's most compact description is just
a statement of that present macro state
if I say the gas is on one side of a box
that's it that's the most compact
description of that present macro State
it may be true that the gas came from
one tiny slice of the volume in the box
at an earlier time or it might be true
that the gas used to be spread
throughout the box and just through a
random fluctuation it moved all onto one
side either one of those pasts is
completely compatible with the present
macro state the gas is on one half of
the box
so you're adding extra stuff when you
add a low entropy boundary condition to
that description of the macro state so
that's a feature of macro State so yes
if you have a good macro coarse graining
you describe current macro States purely
in terms of their of their present
configuration so adding a low entropy
boundary condition
is an extra piece of information like it
or not in fact it's an incredibly
powerful extra piece of information
since in the space of all macro states
in the space of all microstates
corresponding to a certain present macro
state the overwhelming majority of them
will have come from a higher entropy
past and go to a higher entropy future
so I really think that adding in the
extra low entropy initial condition is
not only extra but it's a hugely
leveraged extra bit of information it's
a tiny word right so it has low
algorithmic information content I agree
with that but it's far from necessary
just to deal with the present macro
state and it gives us an enormous amount
of handle on what happened in the past
but it's extra so I think that's why you
sort of have to include it as an extra
assumption because without that
assumption you wouldn't be able to say
the things we want to say about
reconstructing things in the past from
the present moment
John Hamel says there are various
conditions like certain brain injuries
that prevent people from independently
developing complex plans which project
themselves into the future people
suffering from such conditions may be
otherwise lucid and healthy why would it
be wrong for me to push such people onto
the truck going to the slaughterhouse to
be killed in the same way as the cattle
so I think this is a very reasonable
question to ask let me parenthetically
once again editorialize a little bit I
know from having mentioned issues
involving vegetarianism and eating meat
and so forth in the past these are
highly emotionally charged issues and I
get that and that's okay right it's not
like a mistake to be emotionally
invested in this it's kind of a big deal
but my goal in this podcast and
elsewhere in my life is to have as
rational a conversation about these
issues as we can even when the issues
are highly emotionally charged these
issues are hard it's hard because moral
philosophy is hard so we I think we have
to respect the hardness of it all and
not immediately go to the most
emotionally charged language that we can
find now it's perfectly okay to say you
know I'm not in it for the rational
discourse I think I know what the
rational answer is I'm in it to change
hearts in mind
right to to you know reach people at a
visceral level to be an activist not an
intellectual and then by all means you
know that then the emotionally resonant
language makes perfect sense but when
you talk about putting people on two
trucks going to slaughterhouses you're
not trying to have the most rational
discussion you can you're trying to make
an emotional appeal so I don't
necessarily accuse John you of this
doing this right now I'm letting you
know that this is how it appears to
other people and you know again if you
just want to be an activist and convince
people that's fine but let's I would be
more in favor of like trying to be as
clear eyed about it as you can my mind
about these issues is not at all made up
I'm very open to listening to different
people's opinions and ideas about this
which is why I mentioned these things in
my podcast conversations having said all
that I think that you know this is
there's very often whenever anyone sort
of tries to draw a line between here is
what we can eat and here is what we
can't eat no matter where you draw the
line people will argue over where the
line should be drawn and that's a
completely appropriate thing to do in
the case of those of us who think is
perfectly okay to eat meat to eat
animals there's often you know you try
to explain why you treat animals
differently than you treat human beings
there's a move that is made that says
well but some human beings are not going
to fit into your line drawing as human
beings they're gonna be on the other
side because they have brain injuries or
disabilities of some sort or another I
don't find these arguments in particular
persuasive at all because I have no
trouble whatsoever drawing the line at
the species level rather than the
individual level if someone is a person
if someone is a human being then I can
treat them according to certain rules
whether or not they have the mental
capacities of the typical human being so
I think that I had no trouble whatsoever
just as a simple answer to this question
saying yes it is wrong to push such
people onto the truck going to the
slaughterhouse so that's the answer to
the question but of course it brings up
a lot of very very interesting issues
you know when I was just in Australia we
I was right at the time when the next
person coming
to Australia to do a tour with thinking
is Peter singer the very famous
philosopher and one of the on the one
hand he is sort of the intellectual
leader of the animal rights movement
right you know he thinks that animals
he's a vegetarian he thinks animals not
be killed etc but he's also you know as
a philosopher tried to draw these lines
very carefully rather than just you know
be emotional about it and he's gotten in
trouble because he is act you know one
of the things if a Lhasa first sometimes
do is they have a set of moral
intuitions and they try to build them up
into a system and then they say well I
should believe what the system tells me
and sometimes when the system tells you
something counterintuitive you should
say well maybe my system building wasn't
very good but other times you might want
to say I should believe in the system so
singer is very good at believing in his
own system and sometimes it leads him to
say things about the rights of disabled
infants or mentally injured people that
are not compatible with most people's
moral intuitions it's subtle and I'm not
going to be able to correctly state
exactly what his position is but let's
just say it in that way so people
protested that he was going to come and
actually the venue in Auckland where he
was supposed to speak canceled his
engagement they found another venue I
think it's a very bad idea to cancel an
engagement like that like whatever you
might think about Peter Singer and his
ideas you know he's a super smart
intellectual irrational world leading
philosopher he's not some you know
activist for anything you know anything
inhuman or ugly or anything like that
he's exactly the kind of person who if
you disagree with which is fine you
should be trying to persuade with reason
and logic not by canceling his speech
but anyway that was sorry that was a
little digression the point is the you
know the the fact that an individual
human being is not capable of projecting
themselves into the future I get that I
would still want to protect their rights
as a human being because they're a
member of the species that does have
that capability but also I think that
most people I'm not I'm not up on the
all the different levels of mental
injuries that you can have here brain
injuries and so forth but most people
even with the injuries that I'm Oh
we're of are able to understand that
they are being put on a truck going to a
slaughterhouse right in a way that a cow
is not of course maybe you can argue
that the cows are they complain etcetera
you know they they probably cows are
able to have a little bit of
anticipation of what's happening next
and I think that's a perfectly good
argument to have whether or not that is
enough to put them in a different
category
okay roe heat says what do you think
about the late Freeman Dyson's belief
that there are more pressing matters
than climate change which may not
statistically be that big a deal
statically you've written here I'm not
sure what that means but anyway yeah I
think the late Freeman Dyson was
completely wrong about climate change in
many ways of course the argument that
there are more pressing matters may or
may not be true you know I am a belief
as I talk I'm a believer as I talked
about in the podcast with Martin Rees
that nuclear proliferation is a huge
deal for us here on earth I have no real
way of judging whether it's a more
pressing matter than climate change but
I also have great belief in humanity's
capability to handle more than one thing
at once in fact I think it's kind of
necessary so the fact that there's a
more pressing matter is completely
irrelevant to me you know I think that
climate change is a hugely pressing
matter and we should deal with it so I
think the Freeman Dyson was just wrong
about that Brad Wells says would you
please comment on the state of
supersymmetry and by extension string
theory given the null results coming out
of the Large Hadron Collider to date my
understanding is that most supersymmetry
variants have strong correlation between
the massive at least some supersymmetric
particles and the mass of the Higgs is
this a deafening silence or just a work
in progress there's a great question I
think it's a very complicated answers a
complicated set of issues to do justice
to so on the one hand it's very
important to say that both string theory
and supersymmetry don't automatically
predict anything at the Large Hadron
Collider this is part of the problem
with these models is that their
frameworks and there's many many
specific ways to have models within them
and so it would have been great if we
had found supersymmetric particles at
the LHC it would have had almost nothing
to say about string theory I mean
supersymmetry and string theory are
different things string theory predicts
supersymmetry but supersymmetry doesn't
predict string theory so it would have
given as a Bayesian a tiny little boost
to string theory if we had found
supersymmetry the LHC
but it's only a tiny little boost
because you can absolutely have super
symmetry without string theory now the
whether or not you should have expected
supersymmetry at the LHC I think I did
write a blog post right made my
prediction ahead of time but it's
something like 50 percent that I
personally predicted that you'd be able
to find supersymmetry at the LHC so I
don't think it was very very strong
there was a whole set of arguments which
I think were reasonable that said look
we have the Higgs boson it's clearly at
a mass scale much lower than what you
would expect if you didn't know anything
else we have an explanation for how to
explain that low mass scale mainly
supersymmetry cancelling out certain
radiative correction certain quantum
Corrections to the mass of the Higgs if
that explanation is the right one then
you should find supersymmetric particles
at the LHC but of course the reason why
the lord that why the higgs boson has a
low mass might have nothing to do with
that particular supersymmetric solution
to the hierarchy problem as its called
even if supersymmetry is still right so
if you didn't know about the higgs boson
in the hierarchy problem if you were
just doing supersymmetry
you wouldn't automatically say that the
supersymmetric particles should be at
the electroweak scale where we could
find them at the Large Hadron Collider
which by the way we might still you know
it might be the word they're just around
the corner we haven't found them but
it's absolutely true that we could
easily in the space of all possible
models found them a long time ago so I
do personally think that the fact that
we found so what I personally think is
the fact that we've found nothing other
than the Higgs boson so far is telling
us an awful lot
forget about supersymmetry miss
supersymmetry is a good idea but it may
or may not be true but regardless of
supersymmetry it's still
true that in our usual way of thinking
there is this weird unlikeliness that
the Higgs boson would have the low mass
that it does that problem still arises
and not only supersymmetry but sort of
almost any easy straightforward answer
to that question predicts extra
particles and the energies that are
visible the Large Hadron Collider and we
haven't found any of them so that is
absolutely saying something not only
have we not found that but we haven't
found the dark matter particles that
would have been an easy fit into
supersymmetry or other weak scale
theories we solved the cosmological
constant problem etc so I am very open
to the idea that all these little clues
are telling us that there's something
utterly wrong about our way of
predicting what masses of these
particles should be our way of
distinguishing what is natural and what
is not natural now I know that some
people say well we just shouldn't have
made those predictions at all we have no
idea what's natural I don't buy that
either I think that you know physicists
tried to do the best they can and until
we have a better idea just we should you
go with what we have so we have
arguments that say that the low mass of
the Higgs is not natural and therefore
we should try to explain it now you can
say those arguments are wrong but I only
am persuaded by you saying that if you
have another reason to explain why the
Higgs boson has the mass that it does
and those reasons are very hard to come
by I've tried myself I've made zero
progress you know I've had some ideas
none of them panned out so I hope that
other people are taking seriously and I
think it's true that other people are
taking seriously the idea that the
deafening silence at the LHC is a kind
of a clue that a different approach is
needed that's easy to say the hard part
of course is to figure out what the
different approach should be there's an
infinite number of potential different
approaches one could take Zachary stopa
says why do scientists when debating
each other when one person stops
speaking the other before the retort
always begins with the word good do you
guys know this is a thing so I think
it's a thing yeah I think that we do
know I'm not sure if everyone does it I
know I do it and I think to be honest I
picked it up from David Albert who
was a philosopher not if he's trained as
a physicist but he's a philosopher now
you probably have heard our podcast
episode together and David very famously
and very obviously says good in that
sort of way all the time I think it's a
good thing I get why it's done what
you're doing is you're saying we're
having a logical rational conversation
we're trying to first come to some
agreement on things and then move
forward the word good signifies okay
we've understood something now mutually
let's move on to the next thing so I
mean maybe it's a verbal tic but I think
that there's a much worse verbal tics
out there Peter Golay says can you
please comment on the recent
discrepancies in determining the Hubble
constant due to different methods of
measuring the expansion rate of the
universe I don't have much comment on it
I am moving forward on the assumption
that will go away
I don't know that will go away I hope it
doesn't go away I hope that it's a huge
deal and teaches us something really
profound about the universe that we
don't currently understand but it's one
of those cases where again it's a good
Bayesian there's no easy explanation for
I should I should explain for those of
you who are not following this
discrepancy there's something called the
Hubble tension crisis you can measure
the Hubble constant the rate of
expansion of the universe directly by
looking at galaxies and supernovae
nearby and seeing how far they are away
and how fast they're moving away from us
there's also kind of indirect way using
the Cosmic Microwave Background and the
evolution of the asymmetries and
temperature and so forth these ways
should give the same answer and they
give slightly discrepant answers exactly
how big the discrepancy is is you know a
matter of debate but it seems to be big
enough that people are worried that
these two methods are giving different
answers again I think it'll just go away
because all these methods are really
really hard and it's easy to
underestimate your systematic errors and
also because there's no obvious
explanation for why that would be true
so you know in 1998 when we found that
the universe was accelerating rather
than decelerating a huge part of why
that really remarkable and surprising
result was so easy to accept was because
we instantly had a theory that predicted
it right the cosmological constant and
that's just I think that's correctly
taken in a Bayesian framework
to be a good reason to give a certain
experimental result extra credence so I
know that people are taking this result
very seriously you know as a researcher
you have to choose which results to take
seriously and which not you know my mode
these days is to not be an ambulance
chaser trying to explain the most recent
tension in one or the other experimental
result my mode recently is to say you
know I'd rather take a step back we have
standard models in particle physics and
cosmology and gravity they're very very
good at fitting the data they're not
very good at fitting together so I
wouldn't be more interested in the
foundations of these subjects and figure
out how to fit them together then try to
figure out whether or not the most
recent experimental result is actually
telling us something Frank concrete's
says with regard to your and Max tegmark
Society of 50% to eternal inflation
theory and it's outcome of a multiverse
could you express your thoughts on just
one possible alternative that would
address the fine-tuning of constants of
the universe in which we reside so
there's different kinds of things that
people mean when you say fine-tuning
sometimes you just mean the numbers are
very different than what you might
naively expect like we already talked
about with the Higgs boson mass or the
vacuum energy sometimes you mean the
fine-tuning that allows for the
existence of life in the universe so in
either case you know the most obvious
alternative explanation is we got lucky
that's it there is no explanation this
is just how the world is we happen to
live in a universe that allows for life
to exist there you go you know all of
these arguments about naturalness and so
forth are not ever airtight right when
you say that the values of the constants
of nature are fine-tuned that's not the
same as saying that there is some
disagreement between theory and
experiment that's just saying that if we
randomly picked the constants of nature
given some measure on the space of all
possible constants of nature we would be
surprised at these particular values who
knows what that measure should be and I
don't think anyone thinks that we do
randomly pick the constants of nature so
if it is what it is that's an absolutely
perfectly okay explanation for these
things
the other thing which I'm always a big
advocate of is understanding that we
don't know the conditions under which
life can arise if someone handed you the
laws of physics and didn't and you
didn't know about the periodic table and
the nuclei and chemistry in life and
whatever you wouldn't be able to look at
the standard model or the core theory
laws of nature and say oh yes that
allows for life but if I change this
parameter it wouldn't right we are lucky
enough to ex post facto know that the
laws of physics that we actually have
around us allow for life but knowing
whether or not other laws of physics
would allow for life is an incredibly
hard problem so I am not at all
confident that we can even say that the
laws of physics are fine-tuned for life
to exist Anders says imagine a cat in
freefall with his back toward the ground
the cat will rotate itself to land on
all fours how does the cat do this
without violating conservation of
angular momentum
I read the official explanation I don't
really understand it so I'm sorry Anders
this is just not the kind of physics I'm
very good at i'm self-aware enough to
know that there's a whole book by greg
Gabor about this and other sort of
feline physics problems if you're really
interested in it but even though I'm not
gonna be able to give you the complete
answer I will tell you the trick to
understanding the answer which is
there's a difference between the
idealizations that physicists use when
understanding and talking about the
universe and the real messy way the
universe works so sure angular momentum
is conserved for an isolated system
cat's falling down are not isolated
systems you know they have different
moments of inertia that interact in
different ways with the air around them
it's never exactly true that they have
zero angular momentum when you drop them
there's a lot of messy realities that
come in between you and the simplified
spherical cow explanation that we
physicists will often give so you should
never be very surprised that the real
world is a little bit more intricate and
complicated than the world of physics
explanations
Jake Johansson says can you give me one
of your classic style explanations on
how we know that hidden variable theory
is wrong I'm not entirely sure that I
fully grasped what I've read about it so
far so we don't know that hidden
variable theory is
hidden variable theories could be right
also known as pilot wave theories or
bohmian mechanics or deployed bomb
theory these are versions of quantum
mechanics that say that in addition to
the wavefunction there are extra
variables that also tell us what we're
going to observe once we actually do
make a quantum observation so the the
rough motto here is that the reason why
let's say in a double slit experiment
electrons sometimes appear particle like
and sometimes wave like this because
they are both there really is a wave the
wave function and there really is a
particle the electron okay so that could
be right you know I don't know I doubt
it very much because number one most
importantly I just completely have no
need for that right I think of the wave
function alone provides exactly the same
explanatory power namely in the
many-worlds interpretation so why in the
world would I add extra variables on top
of it in the these hidden variable
theories you still have a wave function
the wave function still obeys the
Schrodinger equation the wave function
still represents part of reality then
you add extra stuff on top of it to pick
out one of the worlds that an Eveready
and would say that we live in and I just
don't see the need to actually do that
it is weird many variable theories is a
weird theory because the wave function
pushes around the particles but the
particles do not push around the wave
function if they did we experimentally
rule out a bowl very very quickly and
there's another reason why modern
physicists don't give it a lot of
credence namely that it was developed at
the hidden variable theories in the
context of nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics where you have a particle with
a position etc of course these days we
use quantum field theory to describe the
world and if you care about gravity
there are those of us including myself
who think that even quantum field theory
it's not up to the task and yet to look
beyond that and you need so let's let's
put it the charitable way in these
hidden variable theories whenever you
say oh it's not particles it's fields oh
it's not field - something else you have
to start from scratch and figure out
what the hidden bear
Able's are going to be okay I personally
think that's gonna be a really really
hard thing to do for quantum gravity etc
maybe impossible even for quantum field
theory people have done it people have
made progress in that direction but it
doesn't look pretty it doesn't sort of
naturally fall together whereas hidden
variables whereas sorry with many worlds
in these different versions of the
theory are just plug and play you just
have a Hamiltonian that makes the
wavefunction move and then your job is
to interpret it correctly and that's the
job we're trying to do james kaduk said
I'm curious about the tools you use as a
theoretical physicist as well as your
personal preferences when doing
theoretical work how much of your time
is spent in front of a piece of paper
versus a whiteboard chalkboard versus a
computer do you geek out on writing
instruments like specific brands of
pencils or fountain pens or whatever so
I'm not a big geek about those things
like I get it I saw my best friend's
care a lot about their writing
implements and their chalk and so forth
when my I actually do physics 98% of it
is me writing in one form or the other
not working at a computer so you know
coding or doing numerical simulations is
a tiny tiny part not zero but a tiny
part of my own working life it has
traditionally been pen I don't really
use pencils ever my favorite pen I do
have a favorite kind of pen but it's not
like a fancy one it's a cheapo uniball
vision elite I love these pens and I try
to get them whenever I can
so I have a big supply of them but okay
I'm very happy to use whatever pen is is
around I've been experimenting as I
think I've said with using an iPad and
an Apple pencil it's very very good
there's a number of huge benefits of
writing with the iPad and the Apple
pencil namely you can cut and paste you
can annotate PDFs you can sign documents
and things like that there's also a
pretty big downside which is that the
access time is just slow like if I have
a 10 page long calculation and I'm
writing on page 10 I need a result that
was on page 2 on paper it's trivial you
just look at it and the iPad you I like
scroll down and try to find in
back up and remember so it's still not
anywhere close to the convenience level
of pen and paper for looking at previous
pages or stuff like that
I do sometimes very often use a chalk
board when or a wore a whiteboard I
don't really care I'm not a fanatic
about that certainly when I'm talking to
students or collaborators we're standing
in front of chalkboards or whiteboards
all the time alexander kuvvatov says is
the collective unconscious real in any
useful sense of the word so the
collective unconscious again I'm not an
expert on this but it's a concept from
Jungian psychology I presume since I'm
not an expert I'm just going to speak in
vague generalities here there's
different ways to think about it right
like there's the idea that there is
collective memory that is literally
carried on by oral traditions and
written traditions and handed down and
different cultures share stories and
mores and folk ways and traditions
versus something a little bit more
spooky where there's sort of some
non-verbal non-literary transmission of
information from minds of different
generations to the others my impression
is that the young'uns are or young
himself was pretty spooky about this
stuff and to that extent I think that
it's not real at all but there might be
a more sort of metaphorical allegorical
sense in which the traditions that we
hand down function as a collective
unconscious in some way I don't have a
strong feeling about that thomas Prunty
says if I recall correctly in classical
electromagnetics you arbitrarily select
an arrow of time by picking [ __ ]
potentials over advanced potentials is
the situation different in quantum
electrodynamics how does that fit in
with the entropy driven arrow of time
it's not different in quantum
electrodynamics at all it's the same
story in my mind it's exactly the same
as the entropy driven arrow of time the
fact that there are no electromagnetic
waves that are focusing in on an
oscillating electron so sorry let me I
should back up for those of you who are
not familiar with this story if I shake
an electron spherical waves of
electromagnetic radiation move away from
that shaking electron
light that's where all the light comes
from that is in your room right now if
the actual configuration of stuff in the
universe was completely symmetric toward
past in future that means that when you
shake an electron there should be a set
of spherically symmetric waves focusing
in on it but there are not okay that's a
difference between the past and the
future and I think that's because of a
low entropy boundary condition in the
early universe because if it weren't for
such a boundary condition we'd be in
thermal equilibrium we'd be an
electromagnetic equilibrium there'd be
exactly the same number of
electromagnetic waves hitting the
electron as leaving it so to me it's the
same story not everyone agrees I think
those people are wrong clyde schechter
says on a few occasions you've said that
if space is closed then it is either a
sphere or a torus are these the only
possibilities or just examples these are
just examples I'm sorry if I ever gave
the misimpression that way I will often
say if space is closed like a sphere or
a torus because those are the closed
manifolds if people are very well aware
of it is absolutely possible that space
that is the space of the whole universe
we're talking about now is closed but is
neither a sphere nor torus is something
more topologically complicated there was
a lot of excitement in the 1990s there's
a lot of interest experimentally and
asking could the universe be negatively
curved and have a complicated finite
topology and could we actually observe
that in the Cosmic Microwave Background
I mean roughly speaking the answer is
we've tried now we've collected the data
and it's not there we see no evidence
observational II for that topology but
it could just be larger than the
observable universe that's that's
completely a possibility Philip my 'men
says my question is about zero
amplitudes and near zero amplitudes to
zero presumably this is the amplitude of
a quantum mechanical wave function the
specific possibility within it due zero
amplitude events still happen but with
with zero or do they not happen in a
fundamentally different way from simply
happening with smaller and smaller with
yeah I think they don't happen there's
there's no such thing as happening with
zero width that's a difference I think
there's a fundamentally different thing
there are things in the wavefunction
for which there can be zero amplitude
and you say that those things don't
happen now you might argue that you know
in the real world if there's a
continuous possibility of amplitudes the
chances that you will get exactly zero
are very small but there's sort of
counter arguments to that like as my
favorite example is always there's zero
amplitude for a quantum transition
between two different states with
different electric charge okay we say
the technical term there is that there
are super selection sectors for
electrical charge but if you want to say
like if you have a spin that does a spin
up and spin down can you truly really
absolutely get it into a situation where
the amplitude for observing spin down is
exactly zero that might be harder to do
but conditionally counterfactually if
you did then yes it would just not
happen it doesn't happen with with with
with zero Brendon Hall says do you
believe in the circularity of language
and definitions sorry do you believe
that the circularity of language and
definitions is a true problem for
philosophy I'm reminded of your
conversation with Philip Goff where he
seemed to invoke the problem of circular
definitions to justify intrinsic natures
do you feel a similar urge to solve a
problem of definitions like Philip does
I think if I understood that discussion
that we had correctly that Philip is
worried about the fact that you know you
had things like mass and force and
physics but you can't define perfectly
well any one of those concepts without
also defining the others right need to
find them in terms of each other I do
not think that's a problem at all you
know I think that as I think I said in
that conversation what I think you do is
you have a mathematical formalism that
you call your theory of physics and
there are some axioms some definitions
and things do absolutely you know relate
to each other within that formalism and
then you say that that map's on to the
world and I am kind of a coherent issed
when it comes to truth so I think that
it's important that your system fit
together that all your definitions be
mutually sensible but that's not really
a problem I don't think that there's any
grounding like I think that um as I
discuss in the big picture this is a
philosophical difference
different kinds of people I'm someone
who doesn't think there needs to be an
absolutely firm foundation that you
can't question and then you build
everything on top of that foundation
there is at the bottom in my mind a
bottom level set of laws of physics even
though we don't know what they are but
our knowledge of the laws of physics is
not foundational on anything it's always
contingent it's always like well this is
the best we can do we're trying to fit
in everything we understand logically
and mathematically with all the
empirical data that we have and I think
that's fine I don't think it's really a
problem at all in fact I think it's sort
of inevitable there's really no other
way to do it Santiago Torres says what
does physics have to say about how we
should think about the concept of
causation it is is it correct to say
that we should not apply the concept of
cause beyond the limits of our
experience to describe any fundamental
aspect of reality well I wouldn't say
the limits of our experience I think the
concept of cause is as some of you know
from my previous discussions a higher
level emergent phenomenon so when you
stub your toe and it hurts
you are absolutely within your rights to
say my toe hurts because I stubbed it
because I banged it against the table
okay there's nothing wrong with that
you're not making mistake when you do
that but that kind of language which
makes perfect sense in the macroscopic
world of our experience ceases making
sense at the microscopic level or even
the sort of pristine level of Newtonian
mechanics where you don't have entropy
you don't have an arrow of time you just
have very simple systems obeying
reversible deterministic laws of physics
in those senses in those cases where you
have deterministic reversible laws the
usual notion of cause and effect ceases
to have its usual oath right it's not
that anything goes it's that it's
replaced by a set of laws by a set of
patterns usually differential equations
so there's still a way of describing the
relationship between the situation of
the world at one moment of time and
another moment of time but that
description is not in terms of cause and
effect its term it's in terms of the
laws of physics Girard drivin says okay
sitting
Adham clock on the floor and one at the
ceiling the one at the ceiling where
there's less gravity ticks faster with
my not good developed physics mind
I call it excitement for now is there a
limit to this excitement the the
presumably that's the fastness of the
ticking the speed of oscillating of the
atom from being in a gravity field to a
place where there is no gravity field so
I think this is gonna come up yeah this
is the very next question it's gonna
come up also let me ask the next
question and answer them both together
the next question is from David lang who
says special relativity tells us the
faster we move in space the slower our
clock runs in time and it's symmetrical
the world's fastest man
Usain Bolt goes through the slowest time
according to his caesium stopwatch I've
edited this for length a little bit his
watch would show even less time than the
official timekeeper because it was in
motion he set the record for greatest
time dilation by a human on foot at a
hundred meters he has earned the right
to be called the world's slowest man
through time so let me just say a few
things that I think are true about
relativity and time that are relevant to
both of these questions are ours and
David's I would really be reluctant to
ever say that clocks tick faster or
slower because if you were there with
the clock you would always see it
ticking at 1 second per second what else
could you possibly see it ticking act
because all of the clocks including your
mental clocks and your perception would
be ticking would be affected by gravity
or by your velocity in exactly the same
way so there is a rate at which clocks
tick one second per second and two
Gerard's question yes there is something
called zero gravitational field flat
space we can come very very close to
that far away from any gravitating
bodies and clocks would tick it one
second per second the only thing you can
do is talk about the relative amount of
total ticks that a clock feels and if
you're really precise about it if you
really want to get it right you can only
compare what the clocks are doing when
they are literally right next to each
other at the same point in space when
two clocks are separated you need to
send a signal back and forth to see what
they're doing and
different ways of sending that signal
will get you different answers so the
really rigorous well-defined way of
doing this is to start clocks at the
same part of space-time send them on
different trajectories and then bring
them back together like you do in the
twin paradox this is exactly the
condition under which you will say the
clock that was in a less gravitational
field had more tix to it than one that
he sent down onto the earth or near the
black hole and came back okay but you're
very tempted to say therefore the clock
that was in the gravitational field must
have been ticking more slowly I would
advocate not saying that or you might
want to say the clock that was carried
by Usain Bolt was ticking more slowly I
would advocate not saying that Usain
Bolt watch Usain Bolt's caesium
wristwatch was still ticking at 1 second
per second it's only the comparison when
he's done running in which the whole
journey was different okay so this is
why I like to use this analogy of
walking like space rather than
space-time you can walk between two
points on a straight line and that'll be
the minimum distance you can possibly
traverse you can also walk on a curved
path between those two points and if you
carry an a domitor with you you're a
domitor we'll say you have walked more
steps more distance even though you went
from the same point to the same point
how is it possible that you went more
distance well I mean no one is surprised
by that right the ticking clocks are
exactly the same way except that you
always go through less time rather than
more distance so don't think of clock's
ticking faster or slower think of taking
a shortcut through time if you either
travel near the speed of light and go
out and come back or you spend a lot of
time in a gravitational field you get to
the future event faster experiencing
fewer ticks of the clock then you would
if you would just stayed out there away
from gravity moving at 0 velocity
cyclopropane says I loved your interview
with Kwame Anthony Appiah
thank you I like that one too the more
you touch on our global identities
versus our smaller pettier nationalistic
identities the more I enjoyed it at what
point do you think nature
governments cultures are able to shed
their guilt for past atrocities how can
I live in the USA as a first-generation
citizen and not acknowledge that my
success here is based on the shoulders
of slaves and the genocide of Native
Americans so I think that there's
there's a little bit of a lesion here
between two different concepts you say
at what point can you shed guilt and and
at what point do you acknowledge that
your success is based on past misdeeds I
think these are two different things
guilt and acknowledgement are very
different things I'm all in favor of
acknowledging and I'm also in favor of
shedding guilt but those are two
different processes you should never
stop acknowledging like I don't think
it's any point at which you've said okay
sorry I did something wrong but
therefore you stop saying that you've
done something wrong or admitting that
you've done something wrong typically
whether it's the United States or
Germany or Japan or anywhere else
because most cultures have bad things in
their past
typically the error is on the other side
right a reluctance to admit that you've
done something wrong in the past it's
not that you are over correcting for
what you've done in the past so I think
it's it's good to to admit and
acknowledge the truth of history that
there have been terrible things done in
the past and some of us have benefited
from those terrible things that doesn't
mean you should personally feel guilty I
don't think that a person should feel
guilty for what their ancestors did I
think they should acknowledge what their
ancestors did it admit the truth of it
and understand that and I'm much more
interested in trying to make the present
conditions fair and equitable than in
feeling bad or feeling good you know I
think you should feel a special pride in
what your ancestors did either you don't
get either pride or guilt for that you
are not around right you should
acknowledge the truth of what they've
done and try to make the present world
as good and equitable and fair as you
can Kirk Briggs said I like the
philosophy of Schopenhauer a lot at the
same time I recognize that he is a total
pig when speaking about women how do you
reconcile it do I let his inappropriate
attitudes influence my opinion of his
philosophy you know I think that uh you
don't I wouldn't advocate letting the
personal failings of people influence
your attitude about their creations
about their works right to the extent
that their works are independent of
their personal foible x' because guess
what everybody has personal foibles okay
this is why I'm not in favor of having
heroes or hero-worshipping I think that
people do good things and you should
give them credit for the good things
they do without making them your hero
because there might be bad things that
they've done or there might not but when
we're talking about public figures or
historical figures we rarely know them
personally right we were rarely know who
they are we rarely know how they treat
people who are on a lower level of
status and power than them maybe they're
very sweet adorable people maybe they're
not but you don't know I don't know and
so I'm not gonna say that they're my
hero or role model I will say that they
have done something good and I will
admire that and you know in terms of
accomplishments in philosophy or science
I think that there's all sorts of awful
people who've done really wonderful
philosophy in science and we should give
them credit for their good philosophy in
science it becomes a much harder
question in my mind when it's art when
it's literature or painting or music
rather than philosophy or science
because the enjoyment that we have of
those things is much more subjective
right you know Isaac Newton may have
been a terrible person he was a terrible
person in many ways that has zero impact
on the efficacy of Newton's laws but you
know if you watched Nanette by Hannah
Gatsby and she makes a good case that
Picasso does not observe does not
deserve your admiration I think it's
hard to argue that Picasso's paintings
were really good but when we learn about
what a terrible person he was does that
color our enjoyment of the paintings and
I think yeah doesn't there's nothing
wrong with that
you know since our enjoyment of the
paintings is purely subjective of course
non objective things like the identity
and the nature of the artist can affect
your enjoyment of them I'm not saying it
necessarily should affect your enjoyment
of it because it's subjective
you can make that choice for yourself
but I think it's completely legitimate
to let it affect your enjoyment of them
dan O'Neill says what if it were your
job to go back in time sit down with
Isaac Newton and explain general
relativity to him how difficult would it
be and what he imagined it would be like
well I hope that sir Isaac would not be
upset that I just said he was a terrible
person in many ways you know I I'd like
to think it wouldn't be that difficult I
mean it would be difficult in the sense
that there's a lot that Isaac Newton
doesn't know compared to what we know
now I mean not just general relativity
but tensor calculus for that matter
vector calculus right there's a lot of
things that we are teaching our physics
students in their first year as
undergraduates that Isaac Newton never
heard of so there's an enormous amount
of background that you would have to
teach Isaac but he was very smart so I
think they do you have an easier time
teaching it to him a zero idea of how
open-minded he was to these new ideas my
guess is that he would catch up very
very quickly you know we are not
intrinsically smarter than people from a
few hundred years ago we just know a lot
more and I think that he would still be
someone who qualifies as a physics
genius even if you went back and tried
to teach him modern physics Graham Henry
says can black holes be viewed as
objects that convert mass energy into
space-time curvature does this mean that
mass energy space-time can be viewed as
a single thing so I don't think that
there's any such conversion process
going on you know we is a weird way that
we talk about black holes because black
holes are weird you know they're and
they're outside our everyday experience
and as I've said many times on this
podcast the singularity of a black hole
is not a point at the middle it is a
moment of time in the future later on
we're gonna get to the Big Bang which is
a moment of time in the past we
visualize these things as points but
they're really not they're really
moments so we will often say matter
falls into a black hole and goes and
hits the singularity and that's true but
it's also true that the matter is still
there
the matter is inside the black hole and
it is moving toward the future and in
the future in some very short period of
time typically it will hit the
singularity but while we're outside the
black hole the matter is still inside
the matter that went into making that
black hole so it didn't get converted
into space-time curvature there's a
relationship an interplay between matter
and space-time that led to a black hole
Rober trucks and rescue says imagine
that Laplace's Demon exists and knows
the position and momentum of every
particle in the universe so we're being
Newtonian for the moment would it be
able to predict that I didn't like a
particular ice cream or that I was sad
three days ago and how sad I was in
other words would it be able to grasp
the quality of my qualia based on just
easy problem properties so I think
there's a little bit of an undefined
question but I think we can put we can
we can fix it up a little bit the point
is what do you mean by Laplace's demon
so Laplace himself had this view of a
vast intelligence that knew the position
and velocity of every particle and could
therefore predict the future in the past
of every particle but the question is
does Laplace's daemon know anything else
right
so in some sense there's a minimal
version of Laplace's demon where
literally the only thing this vast
intelligence knows are the positions and
velocities of particles it doesn't know
that there are things called words or
chairs or planets it just knows a long
list of particles and their positions
like if it were literally a computer
with a data file right a computer with a
data file can do a simulation of a
supernova blowing up but if you asked it
in words you know how hot was the
supernova it would have no idea you
could write a subprogram though right
you could easily add to your program an
extra little routine that said calculate
the temperature and it would be able to
do that so in the point of view of
myself
or anyone else who is a physical list
about consciousness you could easily
imagine a version of Laplace's daemon
that did have access to these quality
questions to what we think of as our
qualia is this is this collection of
atoms a person is this person sad or
happy are they experiencing red
etc for someone like me all of those
supervene on the physical locations of
the particles and therefore are in
principle calculable by a laplace's
demon level intelligence from that
information but you have to tell me
whether or not you've actually given the
demon the calculational capacity and the
right definitions to actually answer
those questions Joshua levine says have
you ever tried psychedelics if so do you
think they can have any true value for
helping you see things in new ways so I
mentioned this a little bit in my recent
podcast with Robin Carhartt Harris the
effects of psychedelics have I have
tried them once in my life I tried LSD
the story is told in Jennifer will let
my wife's book called me myself and why
you know I was not there for I was
mostly there for moral support and to
sort of be the caregiver and you know
making sure everything went wrong so I
was not sort of giving myself over to
the psychedelic experience and in a
complete way so I am in no way claiming
that I really have tried all different
psychedelics and tried them in
appropriate ways and so forth you know I
am someone who believes that on the one
hand psychedelics can be very very
helpful and helping people get out of
addictions or ruts or depressions or
things like that they can help people
with pain management they can help
people face and a life crises kind of
things I'm a big believer in the
therapeutic value of psychedelics your
question is do they have any true value
for helping you see things in new ways
well I don't know what exactly that
means right like I did just to amuse
myself when I did the LSD trip I said
you know this has helped me with the
physics problems that I was working on
at the time the physics research
problems the answer that was certainly
no like it was much harder to write down
equations and solve them when you were
on LSD than when you were not probably
not a surprise I think that it's very
plausible to me that being on
psychedelics might lead you to some sort
of creative breakthrough by seeing
things in a different way I don't think
it gives you any deep insight that is
over and above what you in principle
could get without them right it might
help
eze you get there but everything that is
in principle figure out a bowl on
psychedelics I would argue is in
principle figure out a bowl without them
Stefan bar nagar says how does general
relativity impact the electromagnetic
force more specifically how are
electromagnetic waves atoms molecules
crystals and ultimately macroscopic
objects held together by electromagnetic
forces reacting to vibrating space-time
so I don't think III don't I wouldn't
use the phrase vibrating space-time I
would use I would say curved space-time
you know if an object like the earth is
more or less static than the space-time
around it is more or less static but it
is curved by the earth having its energy
and momentum just sitting there I think
that the short answer to your question
is the whole point of general relativity
is that gravity's Universal that gravity
couples to and interacts with everything
in exactly the same way this was what
led Einstein to the great insight that
we should treat gravity not as a force
moving through space-time but as a
feature of space-time itself as the
curvature of space-time so to the best
of our current understanding of physics
everything whether it's electromagnetism
or ordinary matter particles like
electrons and protons or other forces
like the strong nuclear force feel
exactly the same gravitational force
they feel the same curvature of
space-time so certainly gravity both
effects electromagnetism and is affected
by electromagnetism because
electromagnetic forces have energy and
momentum just like everything else
Liam Apple besaid you've mentioned that
we don't know if the dimensionality
helper space is finite or infinite if it
were infinite do we know if it's
countably infinite or uncountably
infinite I don't think we know that I
can certainly say that the simple
examples that we use in textbooks and so
forth where the dimension at where where
hilbert space is infinite i think it's
safe to say is uncountably infinite but
this stuff actually it turns out to be a
really really tricky question like take
just the simple harmonic oscillator this
is every one simple as possible quantum
system okay
so a ball attached to a spring where
there's an equilibrium where it can just
stay stationary or you can move it away
from the equilibrium and it will
oscillate back and forth there's a
quantum version of that and the question
of whether or not a vector space is
countably infinite or uncountably
infinite can be thought of in terms of
what is the basis for that vector space
and how many basis elements does it have
a countably infant number or an
uncountable even number in the most
straightforward way of thinking about
the simple harmonic oscillator you can
write it down at a basis which is
uncountably infinite the position basis
is it located at x1 or x2 or x3 but
there's another basis the energy level
basis which is discrete and countable I
should by the way say for those who
don't know these words different
versions of infinity exist
Georg contour showed this back in the
19th century countable means a notion of
infinity which looks like the integers
right from minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 0 1 2
3 the counting numbers and their
negative numbers this is a countable
infinity what Cantor showed is that the
continuum the real numbers from minus
infinity to infinity has a strictly
greater set of numbers in it than the
integers does so and they're called
uncountable because you can't count them
there you go we don't know is the short
answer and even in simple examples you
could imagine the answer going either
way
so I'm not sure this there is a there
are certainly people out there who
understand this level of mathematical
nicety within quantum mechanics way
better than I do so you could look that
up on Wikipedia probably more likely
than I would do is a simple harmonic
oscillator an example of a countably
infinite or uncountably infinite hilbert
space once you get to quantum field
theory it's pretty clearly uncountably
infinite because even the classical
theory has uncountably infinite in the
States
just like the harmonic oscillator does
so anyway short answer is no we don't
know I don't know I could see it going
either way
Scott s says in the book powering the
future Robert Laughlin says that we have
two broad choices with respect to
nuclear power there's enough uranium on
earth to either one provide electricity
for about 200 years
via a process that does not lead to
radioactive elements that can be used in
nuclear weapons or to essentially
provide electricity for thousands of
years but the byproducts can be
weaponized he does not discuss thorium
reactors do you know enough about the
subject to comment or can you suggest a
resource for further information no I do
not know enough about this to comment I
I will say the tiny little bit that I
have to say about this is I'm quite
optimistic about non nuclear power for
the long term solar power especially
batteries will get better
etc whether or not nuclear power is is
very very useful in the short term I'm
very open-minded about you know
traditionally I was very Pro nuclear
power but I certainly admit there are
many many details that I'm not an expert
on Martin Rees who knows more about it
than I do
was very Pro nuclear power in our
conversation but 200 years sounds to me
like enough time to figure out other
sources of power and I am extremely
worried about weaponizing nuclear fuel
and nuclear reaction products therefore
if my current state of very primitive
knowledge I'd be much in favor of
processes for nuclear power that did not
lead to radioactive elements that could
be weaponized
Marion markali says I was thinking of
recent experiments which seemed to
conclude that most animals have an
innate number sense and can even do some
basic math doesn't this hint at a
starting point for a more formal
universal communication between us and
other species I don't think so again I'm
not an expert on this but I don't think
that the problems for that we have
communicating with other species or
because we don't have a common language
I just don't think that's the problem at
all I think that our thoughts are just
very different intrinsically right this
is super obvious when it comes to most
animals right when you try to talk to an
ant or a cat you know it can't teach
them a language that will let them cat
with us they just don't have the
capacity to do that for much smarter
animals for you know other primates or
dolphins or
octopus's or whatever I still don't
think that the problem is we don't have
language I think that they don't have
the capacity for language that we do I
mean they do have at some capacity even
dogs and cats have some capacity for
understanding things we say and for
communicating to us with sounds that
they make but there are levels that they
cannot reach right that that is why
human beings are a little bit different
I've never heard any animals be trained
to use the subjunctive mood in a
grammatically proper way for example so
I don't really think it's a language
that is holding us back
Ron Jacobson says is it workable to
approach many worlds by postulate
postulating that the universal
wavefunction is a superposition of all
possible worlds and that whenever we
make a quantum measurement we simply
gain some information that narrows down
which world we happen to live in yeah
you know I think this is a viable way of
thinking about many worlds as far as I
know so that I'll rephrase the
suggestion as instead of saying we are
in one big world that then splits and
differentiates as different subsystems
become entangled with each other is it
okay to imagine there are many worlds to
start but all the worlds to start are
identical and then what happens is they
simply simply become different but all
the number of worlds are already there
from the start people have absolutely
looked into this you know can you do it
that way there are arguments back and
forth I kind of don't care I don't think
it's a crucially important distinction
honestly like my attitude toward the
worlds or is that they are a human
convenience what really exists is the
wave function of the universe and all
else is commentary right so what I would
do to rephrase that question is are we
allowed to talk about quantum mechanics
by subdividing into different worlds
from the start or do the worlds have to
be subdivided later it's certainly more
natural
for me to imagine subdividing into
separate worlds after the individual
experiments are done and quantum systems
become entangled with their environments
because it's only then that the world's
are distinguishable and they can't
interact with each other etc right
to me that's what makes the world's
sensible concept but there are other
ways of talking about it and that's fine
with me that does not violate any of my
deeply held principles
Sandra Suki says my question is about
the black hole information puzzle where
does the randomness in black hole
radiation come from and then I added a
little bit but he goes on to say you go
on to say in Hawking's calculation black
hole radiation seems not to be
deterministic it's truly random even
without any branching how is that
compatible with the many-worlds
interpretation which seems to be a
deterministic theory is this a defect of
Hawking's calculation or of the
many-worlds interpretation well I think
this is exactly the black hole radiation
paradox or puzzle whatever you want to
call it the point is that Hawking's
calculation does not seem to follow the
rules of quantum mechanics it does not
seem to start well so to be very clear
here to anyone who has not been
following in quantum mechanics we start
with a wave function the wave function
of the universe in the many worlds
theory we have an equation the
generalized version of the Schrodinger
equation for whatever situation you're
interested in that shows us how that
equation that wave function evolves and
is completely deterministic in many
worlds that wave function involves more
and more worlds branching toward the
future but the overall wave function is
still deterministic Hawking's
calculation says that that single wave
function evolves into an a super not a
superposition but a mixture of many
different wave functions the technical
term is a mixed state or a density
matrix or a density operator rather than
a single pure wave function so that is
not what many-worlds says that is a
conflict with many worlds the question
is is it a defect of Hawking's
calculation probably that's what most of
us believe right we think that you know
he made some assumptions that don't hold
true in the real world and we're trying
to fix them that is the black hole
information puzzle how do you fix them
turns out to be really really difficult
to fix them but that's what we're trying
to do and you know the
jury is not completely in on whether or
not it's fixable and many-worlds is a
perfectly good description of that or
whether black holes are truly
information destroying which would be
the other alternative price Graham says
in the Q&A after your brief history of
quantum mechanics talk you mentioned
that while writing something deeply
hidden you made 50 quantum spin
measurements for an example you admitted
that in some universe you would have
measured them all spin up you seem to
have shrugged it off like it wasn't a
big deal and would have just thought
someone broke the machine does that mean
that in some branch of the universe
there is a poor physicist who has only
and will only ever measure spin up so
yes that that means exactly that and I
talked about this in the book and again
I think this is going to come up again
later in the AMA so let me explain the
attitude that I think one should have
toward this if you believed in a version
of quantum mechanics that was truly
stochastic that one in which there was a
chance that you would measure twenty
spins in a row or 50 spins in a row and
get all spin up but it was a small
chance that wouldn't bother you right
you think that there's more likely
things that are more typical less likely
things that are less typical if you're
going to believe many worlds at all
you have to understand that there is a
similar attitude toward those things in
many worlds it is true that all the
universes become true but there are way
more where you get the likely outcomes
than the ones which you get the unlikely
outcomes so the probabilities work out
exactly the same way the fact that there
is an extremely extremely low
probability universe that really exists
but one in which the outcomes that the
experiments will be statistically
unlikely is fine you can't guarantee
that every experimenter is always going
to get to the right answers that's just
a feature of statistics I think that we
have a some people have a tendency in
many worlds to say well look all the
worlds are real and I'm going to
implicitly treat them as equally real
treat them is equally important but the
very very low amplitude worlds should be
treated as less important even though
they are real that's the only way that
many worlds is ever going to make sense
petros Pasillas says when a photon is
detected
double-slit experiment how many new
worlds are being created I'm not exactly
sure what this refers to when I mean I'm
not sure what role the double-slit has
here if you fire a photon through a
screen whether it not whether or not it
goes through double slits it will hit
the screen at some point and in the
typical way of thinking about things
where you have an infinite number of
positions where the atoms on the screen
could be an infinite number of positions
where the photon could hit it there are
an infinite number of worlds that the
universe breaks into but of course once
you have an infinity like that you
shouldn't be counting the worlds what
you can do is you can talk about the
relative number of worlds with certain
properties versus other properties so
what we talk about is the relative
number of worlds where the photon hit in
this particular location on the screens
particular non zero area sized box of
the screen you sort of coarse-grain it
and you say what is the probability what
is the fraction of worlds that that's
where the photon landed those are the
kinds of things you can talk about when
you have a continuum of possibilities
it's it's better to think of it as a
continuum of possibilities then as
literally an infinite number of worlds
even though the words work out the same
way Vampira Khan says have you ever
watched the Avatar cartoon and the
answer is no I haven't so I have no wise
things to say about that
Barry Wallace says Kirk or Picard I have
watched Star Trek and I think I'm gonna
say Picard here you know I like both I
like old Star Trek which I grew up with
even though it was already reruns when I
started watching it but I think as
captains go I would rather have John
Luke on my side than james t kirk he
just seems like a little bit more of a
level-headed guy Simon Carter says what
was your opinion of Freeman Dyson and do
you think his stance on climate change
impacted his reputation I think there's
no doubt that Freeman Dyson was an
incredibly good and creative and
technically proficient physicist he
arguably deserved to share the Nobel
Prize you know he helped understand the
renormalization of infinities in quantum
electrodynamics the prize went to
Fineman and schwinger and
tominaga and there's a limit right you'd
only allowed to give the Nobel Prize to
three people but Dyson certainly would
have been perfectly understandable as a
choice along with those folks and he did
a whole bunch of other things he did he
worked on the Oklo natural reactor for
example this thing that in Africa where
there was a naturally occurring nuclear
chain reaction which we can use to put
limits on the change in the values of
physical constants over time has his
stance on climate change impacted his
reputation well I think that you know
his stance on climate change was
damaging it's more damaging to the cause
of doing something about climate change
when a clearly brilliant famous
accomplished scientist says we don't
need to worry about it
then someone who is just off the street
so I think that it bothered people that
he made such a big deal about it but you
know Donald think it affected his
reputation as a physicist I've made his
ability to do calculations in quantum
electrodynamics was just as good as it
ever was
Peter su says in context of the famous
double slit experiment when done with
with light of sufficient intensity it's
my understanding that you can compute
the shape of the interference pattern in
two ways first as a classical
interference between electromagnetic
waves and then also as an interference
pattern between the probability
amplitudes with a quantum wave function
presumably somewhere there's an example
of someone doing this calculation both
ways and showing to get the right answer
this is interesting because a priori one
has no reason to believe that
electromagnetic waves are at all related
to complex probability amplitudes well I
think that's not exactly right you know
there I'm not sure about the phrase a
priori here because you know nothing
here is a priori at all you're
developing a theory and seeing whether
it works but the point is there
absolutely is a relationship between
complex probability amplitudes and
electromagnetic waves the classical wave
that you get in classical
electromagnetism emerges out of the
quantum electrodynamic description and
the way it emerges is that areas in
which the electro electric and magnetic
fields are large correspond to large
number of photons that would be observed
which correspond to a large probability
amplitude for observing a bunch of
photons so I think in fact that the
relationship between them is pretty
straightforward and indeed you do get
the same answer in that limit of a large
occupation number of photons justin
bailey says you said previously of the
existence of the universe is a brute
fact that you accept that's hard for me
old as it is I think the first mover
argument is hard to refute to refute how
do you respond to that argument I think
it's SuperDuper easy to refute to the
first mover argument I mean the whole
point of arguments that are similar to
the first mover argument you know
everything that moves needs a mover but
low blood therefore there's a first
mover is to deny the very first premise
it's not true that everything that moves
needs a mover I mean we've known that
for a thousand years since we first
started to understand conservation of
momentum when you were an Aristotelian
physicist you look around the world and
notice that in order to get things
moving you have to push them but we know
better now there's a thing called
conservation of inertia and conservation
of momentum the natural thing is for
things to be moving and so there does
not need to be any explanation for why
things move and I think that you know
the universe is the same way but in
particular even if it weren't it's not
at all clear that things that apply to
things in the universe necessarily apply
to the universe as a whole so I think
that the right question to ask in the
modern era we know about science is not
what caused or what created or what
brought into motion the universe but
what are the laws of physics that allow
the universe to exist and you can then
ask yourself are there laws of physics
that can describe the universe and its
existence in a perfectly self-contained
consistent internally coherent way and
from everything we know the answer is
yes we don't know completely what those
laws are yet so we might be wrong about
that but we have every reason to believe
that such laws exist you don't need to
imagine there's anything outside the
universe to bring it into existence
humberto nany says besides that we can
only move to the future what other facts
of our universe make it look like we're
inside a black hole I don't think
there's any facts about our universe
that make it look like the inside of a
black hole I am on record as saying
please do not think that the universe is
looks like the inside of a black hole
black holes are things that exist in
otherwise empty space where there is a
region of space with an event horizon
around them with the property that
things can come into the event horizon
and join us in the region but they can't
go out that's what a black hole is that
is not what our universe is as far as we
know at all if anything our universe is
kind of like the time reverse of a black
hole it's kind of like a white hole
where there is a singularity in the past
rather than the future but even then
it's not exactly like that it's the
universe it's a different thing than a
black hole Greg or Johnny luck says how
much time do you spend on these ask me
anything episodes do you prepare the
answers or do you go with the flow live
so I think what I generally do is I try
to get go into the patreon post I cut
and paste all the questions into a
separate text document then I go through
all the questions and I try to edit them
down a little bit you know some some
folks tend to go on a little bit in
their question asking which is fine but
not everyone else listening necessarily
wants to hear the entire question so I
try to edit them down to the essence of
it and while I'm doing that I will think
a little bit about what answer I'm going
to give and then once that editing is
done I can go in and actually answer
them in real time the editing and the
end the thinking about answers will take
a couple of hours two or three hours
typically and then the recording also
takes two or three hours typically I
always aspire to just go through in one
fell swoop and do all the questions it
rarely happens either my voice goes out
or something like that so over the
course of an afternoon on the weekend I
can usually get it done Paul toric says
here's a scenario to explore the ideas
of downward causation and mixing levels
of explanation a crystallographer uses a
very narrow x-ray beam to analyze the
microscopic shifts in metals that have
been subjected to stress she takes an
aluminum automotive part manufactured by
a new process and analyzes the
particularly degree elbow which these
parts typically fall she rotates the
part just so and places it in the
analyzer she subjects the part to a
certain cycle of stresses then rotates
the part to the same orientation and
places the elbow in the same position
with submillimeter accuracy
her microscopic at her macroscopic
actions determined which microscopic
crystals are subjected to x rays and
which aren't
what why doesn't this explanation count
as mixing levels or downward causation
so there's two reasons why I don't think
it counts as downward causation it does
in some sense count as mixing levels
just because the macroscopic level gives
us a description of the world which is
necessarily incomplete if you have a
description of the world where there's
no such things as atoms where there are
pieces of metal and there are you know
machines and things like that you can
deal with them then you can use that
description to describe what happens
only up to the point where your
description doesn't need to require any
reference to atoms if you use your
macroscopic world to observe atoms and
then you take actions on the basis of
what you've observed then you're purely
macroscopic description does not suffice
to explain exactly what happened so you
can eat it you can abet it augment it I
guess is the word I'm looking for here
you can augment it which is what we do
in the real world by using a macroscopic
description that also dips into a
microscopic description when necessary
and then goes back to the macroscopic
description and that's perfectly fine
there's nothing wrong with that but
alternatively you could completely
describe things in the microscopic level
you don't need to refer to a
crystallographer or a machine or
anything you could just refer to what
the atoms are doing and you would get
the right answer if you had Laplace's
deamon level of specificity about what
was going on you would say exactly what
was happening without any reference to
what was happening at the higher level
whatsoever
that's why downward causation is not
necessary for these to understand these
actions andrey Mirabelli
says what criteria do you support for
determining which recurrent process
should be used as the standard good
clock to determine whether one time
interval has the same duration as a
subsequent one so that competing
fundamental theories can be fairly
adjudicated I don't really have any dog
in this fight
as we say this is a technological
question about what makes the best
clocks right you know some frequency of
some atomic transition or nuclear
transitions
something like that that is way more
specific and technological than anything
that I have an expert in sorry about
that
Gregory coos Nick says what's on the
chalkboard behind you in your patreon
profile picture that was a picture taken
at Cal Tech so it's a chalkboard at Cal
Tech with some lagrangians for quantum
field theories behind me or maybe some
actions or something like that but
anyway some equations for quantum field
theory I don't remember the specific
ones in fact I didn't write them they
were there already when we just took the
picture it was in a public area not in
my office
Ramon Rocha says do you enjoy stories
about the paranormal or supernatural and
have you ever personally experienced
something very strange that you couldn't
rationally explain so I enjoy all sorts
of stories about things I don't think
are true I mean I'm a big fan of the
Marvel movies for that matter have I
personally experienced anything that I
can't rationally explain sure there's
plenty of things that I can't explain
the difference I think what you're
getting at is are there things which I
think do not have a rational explanation
and for there the answer is no I think
that again like a good Bayesian we know
enough about the laws of physics and how
they work and how successful they are to
think that whenever something happens
I'm going to put a very very very high
credence in a completely physicalist
naturalist rational explanation it would
have to be a very very blatant and
unmistakable violation of the laws of
physics before I started shifting my
credence --is to something supernatural
or paranormal Sandeep chital a says
presumably the Big Bang started from a
single point one point can only be
arranged one way one microstate equals
one macro state therefore it's the
lowest entropy why is that not right so
it's not right for a few reasons the Big
Bang did not start from a single point
it started well depends what do you mean
right the Big Bang in classical general
relativity is a point at which the
curvature of space-time is infinitely
big and therefore that point is not
described by classical general
relativity so you simply cannot say
anything about it what you should do is
sort of imagine cutting off that point
stopping your description just before
you get there and then what you have is
space and time immediately after the big
in space and space itself could be
infinitely big in extent there is no
limit how big space could be more so
therefore there's no reason whatsoever
for it to be a single point or just in
one microstate or one macro state and
it's more specific than that
right the Big Bang is not a point even
if you cheat and add it back in to the
description the Big Bang is a moment of
time it is a moment that before which
there are no other moments if that is
indeed the description that is true for
the real universe which we don't know
you can you can verify all of this by
thinking about the Big Bang in Reverse
right thinking about a Big Crunch if you
let a whole bunch of matter and energy
crunch and in a contracting universe
instead of expanding as we think that
our past actually did there's absolutely
no reason for the universe to smooth out
as it crunches together all of the
things that we know about the laws of
physics predict that it would get
lumpier and lumpier the higher entropy
states are extremely in homogeneous and
lumpy as you approach that singularity
that's how we know that the real Big
Bang whatever it was that created a
universe it was extremely smooth was
much much lower entropy than it needed
to be
James O'Sullivan says in the double slit
experiment why does the electrons
interaction with the slits not caused
decoherence or the slits themselves not
already entangled with the environment
or is it because this list don't
interact with electromagnetic radiation
we have to be a little bit careful here
I mean the double slit experiment is an
idealization for real slits they might
very well become entangled with the
electron going through if you're not too
careful but in the idealization of the
typical traditional double slit
experiment you're imagining that the
state of the double slits the state of
the barrier through which the electrons
are trying to pass is completely
unaffected by the electron therefore
there is no entanglement generated
between the electron and the slits right
and therefore decoherence is not going
to happen
decoherence as always the entanglement
between the quantum system you're
looking at and the wider environment if
the slits are not affected then is
nothing there entangling the electron
I'll
though Mendez Martens says could the
fact that from the perspective of a
photon the universe seems to be frozen
in time be the reason why in the delayed
choice to slit experiment the photons
interfere with all photons past and
present could it be that all photons
exist at the same time but in different
positions in space so you have to
distinguish between the time that is
read by a clock moving along some
trajectory versus the time is seen from
the outside when people say that photons
experience no time this is just a way of
saying that the literal space-time
interval along a light light trajectory
is zero what it would be more accurate
to say is that there just is no clock
that can pass a bong that can be carried
along by a photon it's not like the
photon is experiencing no time its the
time is not something that the photon
could experience if that's a sensible
distinction to make but of course we
have time passing as the potent as the
photon passes by us there's absolutely
no problem with assigning a time of each
to each point in the photons trajectory
it's just the time that we use as a
coordinate not the time of the photon is
experiencing so I would say there's no
truth to the idea that all photons past
present and future are interfering or
interacting with each other in any way
according to the laws of physics as we
understand them things only interact
when they are at the same moment of time
Linnea Mazzara says is the block
universe an unescapable consequence of
special relativity or can we conjecture
an alternative view of time apart from
the bee theory of time so the bee theory
of time refers to this idea that there
really is a block universe the a theory
in this this nomenclature that was put
forward by McTaggart years ago the a
theory is one in which the present
moment exists and sort of it marches
forward in time so most physicists RB
theorists they believe that all time is
equally real to the sense that they care
which is not very much and one of the
arguments put forward is of course
special relativity in special relativity
there's no preferred way to slice the
universe into moments of time different
observers will do it differently so how
in the world could what is real
depend
how a single observer chooses to slice
the universe into different moments of
time so is that in this capable argument
you know almost all arguments are
escapable i don't want to say it's an
unescapable consequence there's a
philosophical perspective right it's not
really a prediction that is made by some
physical theory so I think that there
definitely as an empirical matter are
people in the world who perfectly accept
special relativity and yet do not accept
the block universe so there you go
it must not be an unescapable
consequence but also you know I I think
that on the flip side of that I believe
that the block universe is perfectly
sensible and would be even without
special relativity I think the simple
fact of conservation of information and
the fact that what you know at one
moment of time is enough to predict the
past present and future is enough to
convince me that the block universe is
the a good perspective to bring to these
kinds of questions a non-anonymous
questioner says physics Outsiders here a
lot of non established theories but it's
hard to separate out what's probable and
what's speculative what are your
rapid-fire unjustified not really
thinking credence --is for these
hypothesis being true
are there any propositions where your
personal credence is differ from most of
the physics establishment so there's a
long list of propositions that I'm being
asked for credence is for so I edit it
down a little bit but most of them are
still here so is dark matter made of
wimps you know I would have said 80%
chance but we haven't found them in the
LHC hasn't found anything so now I'm
down to about 50% chance more than 1% of
dark matter interacts with itself with
dark forces I think that's very unlikely
maybe 5% chance or 10% chance that
that's true something like that it's
conceivable I would love it i'm the
author of various theories along those
lines but I don't see any real strong
evidence for it yet accion's exists I
think that's a good axioms are a good
idea I might put them at a 30 or 40
percent chance of being real magnetic
monopoles exist I think that there's
very very tiny credence that a magnetic
monopole exists that we might find in
our observable universe but it's
possible magnetic monopoles are
conceivable according to the laws of
physics that might actually govern our
universe I just don't think that we have
any lying around
tachyons exist i think is a negligible
credence you know way less than 1%
neutrinos have mass and travel less than
the speed of light I think that's true
99% plus photons have mass and travel at
the speed of light I think that's false
less than 1% supersymmetry something
like supersymmetry at some energy we
don't know where it is I would put I
think it's probably likely it's one of
those things that you know just seems to
make everything nicer if it exists so
maybe 60 or 70% credence on that the
standard model has something really
wrong with it that we've already
discovered but just don't realize it
I think that's unlikely right now so
that's less than 10% chance for me same
as bub for gr less than 2% chance we
have will have replaced the standard
model in my lifetime that's a tough one
that's one where I don't even trust my
own credence is because I really really
really want it to be true that we will
have superseded the standard model in my
lifetime but we don't seem to be right
there we don't seem to be on the verge
or the cusp of it happening so I will
put a 40% credence that we'll have done
it but that might be overly optimistic
or pessimistic it's just very hard to
tell
Jeffery Irving says what's your credence
that we can do an infinite amount of
useful contribution in our future light
cone I expect this to be low but not
zero and I'm curious as to where your
main nonzero term would come from I'm
gonna apologize because I don't know
exactly how to turn this into an
operationally well-defined question I
don't know what an infinite amount of
useful contribution would really be mean
depends on useful it depends on what
sort of measure we use to measure the
amount of usefulness and things like
that I will say that I think that the
simplest version of what we currently
understand about cosmology predicts that
the universe will equilibrate and reach
maximum entropy in some finite time and
so the smart money is on a finite amount
of anything existing in our future like
on any influence we might have but you
know there we don't know so I think that
there's some nonzero credence on any
other possibility so
yeah I I really I can't give a very
specific answer to where the main
nonzero term would come from cuz I'm not
quite sure what I'm being asked to
imagine sorry about that
Abdul absol's says if you were to
organize moving naturalism forward 2.0
sometime this year which five people
would you like to participate in the
conference so I'm gonna I'm gonna punt
on this one a little bit because I don't
like to answer questions like this
because you know I might do it right I
might actually organize a conference but
I haven't done it I don't I haven't
decided what kinds of person I would
invite to something like that so I don't
want to sort of say out loud who I would
invite and then end up not inviting them
does that make sense does that make
sense to you but I think that you can
get an idea of some people who I think
would be good by looking at former
guests of the mindscape podcast and
asking yourself you know which of these
people are the kinds that might do well
at a conference on naturalism you know I
think that someone like Patricia
Churchland I can mention out loud
because she was actually invited to the
first movie naturalism forward
conference and couldn't make it just
because of personal reasons that time
but there's a bunch of people among the
guests who you know have thoughtful
ideas about how the universe works at a
deep level and how we can connect those
two ideas about morality and living in
the universe and consciousness and the
origin of life all these big questions
that natural ists have to face up to so
play the game the other way make up your
own movie naturalism forward conference
out of it pre-existing guests from the
mindscape podcast George Cloon says many
cosmologists believe inflationary
cosmology is the best way to describe
the very early universe however I think
that in a previous podcast you said it
was probably not right what are the main
arguments against this idea and what is
the best competing theory so I don't
think I said it's probably not right I
think that inflation is one of those
things which I put 50% credence on it's
a inflation is really good at certain
things what it's good at will be
different when you listen to different
people giving you the sales pitch for it
I definitely have a minority point of
view on this because I take the entropy
of the early universe problem very very
serious
and inflation makes that problem worse
inflation makes the early universe
sensible by positing and even lower
entropy initial condition than the
conventional Big Bang model does so
that's why I don't think that it's
anywhere near close to a sufficient
answer to why the early universe looks
the way it does but it might be part of
a more comprehensive answer you know in
the paper that I wrote with Jennifer
Chen years ago 15 years ago now about
the multiverse in the arrow of time we
absolutely used inflation as a crucial
element in our theory there's another
paper area with Lisa Randall and Matt
Johnson about changing the number of
dimensions dynamically where again
inflation would play an important role
in connecting a theory like that to
reality so I'm all in favor inflation in
that sense what I really think inflation
does is it gives you leverage for
inventing theories where the initial
conditions of our universe are set at
the Planck scale at the Planck distance
the physical size of our universe might
only be 1 Planck length across an
inflation could help explain how it
expands up to the universe we see
whereas in conventional hot Big Bang
cosmology at the moment when the
curvature and density was at the Planck
scale the physical size of our
observable universe was more like a
centimeter across which is some crazily
Jai humongous length scale for particle
physics to try to explain so in some
sense inflation gives you an attractive
easy target that's the good news the bad
news is it requires extra fine-tuning to
make it happen and we don't really have
a compelling mechanism for which it
really did happen we have not I guess we
have many mechanisms we don't have any
way of choosing between the different
possibilities Rik coyote says if
neutrinos are so multitudinous why are
they so hard to detect it seems to me
that they're just sheer numbers where
the detectors going off constantly so I
think that you're not thinking about
this hard enough Rick of course for any
one detector there will be a probability
that if a neutrino goes through it the
detector will go off okay because
neutrinos are very weakly interacting
that probability is a small number
so you take that probability times the
number of neutrinos passing through to
get the noble number that you expect to
see in any one run of your experiment no
matter how many neutrinos there are I
can invent a probability that any one of
them will be involved will be detected
that is so small that the expected
number of neutrinos you see is zero or
very very close to zero there's much
much less than one let's put it that way
so I this is a case we just have to like
write down the equation right you can't
just sort of Intuit it off your head
there's always an interaction that is so
weak that no matter how many particles
there are you will not observe them
Victor Alejandro Viner says I have a
silly question this time around do you
know Shawn B Carroll have you read his
books on evo-devo evolution and
development I do know my evil twin Shawn
B Carroll he's a couple of years older
than me but he has the beard so that's
how you know he's the evil twin he is
one of the very few people I will
happily admit is a future target for the
mindscape podcast he wrote writes great
books about evolution and development I
highly recommend them Paul Hess says
many-worlds is often described by take
talking about world's existing with all
possible choices being made but why do
we believe for any good reason that
Shawn's freewill is due to random
quantum processes instead of just being
dependent on classical but currently
unknown States and brain mechanisms
relating to the state of his brain such
as his mood etc well Paul I recommend
that you buy a book that I've seen on
sale called something deeply hidden
which talks about exactly this kind of
thing a great detail and that book will
go to great lengths to tell you that
there is no relationship whatsoever
between the many-worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics and choices being
made by human beings
there's just no relationship at all one
way or the other it's not that making
choices cause it causes world a branch
it's not that worlds branching causes
choices to be made these are two
separate things and indeed I agree with
you I think that for the most part the
workings of the brain are perfectly
classical but we just don't know the
specific microscopic States that's what
gives us uncertainty about what
decisions are gonna be bait not anything
to do with quantum mechanics
Zain Jacob says I'm a master's student
in applied math doing research and
scientific machine learning and recently
I've been thinking about how to do
effective reduced order modeling when
you don't have good intuition for the
underlying dynamics
this relates pretty naturally to the
problem of coarse graining quantum
mechanics so my question is essentially
how should one go about finding an
effective coarse graining when you
really have no idea what exactly you're
looking for I think this is a really
good question actually and I think it is
one that has been under addressed in the
literature in part because people don't
take many worlds seriously enough ash
Meads saying who is a student at Caltech
he and I have been trying to develop
what we call mad dog Eveready anism
where not only do you have the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics but you don't assume any
structure pre-existing that gives you a
classical handle on the wavefunction you
have to get that structure to emerge out
of it and so there's good ideas from
other people about how locality and
spatial positions can emerge we wrote
one paper a shmita nigh on how you could
use principal components analysis to get
a coarse graining where you didn't know
much about the quantum dynamics but I
think that there's a paper we're writing
right now which is much more relevant to
the question you're asking on what we
call quantum me rheology that's the
question of how you divide systems in
divide holes into parts that's of Murray
ology is the relationship between holes
and parts so to an aviary and where you
think that the whole world is described
by a single wave function if that's all
you know is the wave function and the
Hamiltonian that tells you how its
evolved then the mechanism to go from
there to a certain way of characterizing
the wave functions that you can
coarse-grain it is highly non-trivial it
has to do with entropy you'll be
unsurprised to learn and it has to do
with emergence and it has to do with the
existence of effective higher-level
descriptions which require just an
incomplete amount of information
basically what you want to do is look
for the factorization into system and
environment so that the system states
have as much classical behavior
as they can well the minimum amount of
entanglement growth between the system
and its environment so this is what you
need to look like an emergent
coarse-grained higher level classical
world but making that operational I
think there's still a lot of work to be
done in that so I don't think there's
any final answers quite yet Maxime
Alexandrov it says my question is
regarding quantum computers let's say it
will soon be possible to create a very
accurate model of a small part of the
universe for example our moon what would
be the discritization level of such a
model as far as I understand with
traditional computers there's always a
limit in which you could say aha
you missed part of the simulation
because of the discretization could such
a model be indistinguishable from our
real moon could quantum model even on
subatomic particle level and therefore
it could it be a real world inside a
real world so I'm not exactly sure what
you're saying but I think I I think I
understand you know even though there
are a finite number of qubits in a
quantum computer as we said because
Hilbert space is a vector space there's
always an infinite number of quantum
states that could be described by that
set of qubits unlike a truly classical
set of bits where there's only a finite
number of ones and zeros right a single
qubit has an infinite number of possible
States because you can add any linear
combination of spin-up and spin-down for
example however that is not enough to
model something like the moon which has
a lot of particles to correctly model
something like the moon without any loss
of information due to discretization or
something equivalent to discretization
would require a Hilbert space as large
as the Hilbert space of the moon so
roughly speaking you would need a
quantum computer as large as the moon
and then you're not really computing the
moon you're just simulating it you're
just making a copy of it Paulina Baran
says I'm interested in what your stand
is on universal basic income so I'm in
favor of it I think it's a great idea
you know I'm someone who believes that
you help people out by giving them money
right I'm not someone who believes that
you're cheating people out of the chance
of getting dignity by not giving them
money and insisting that they work you
know working is good for some people
it's
and bad for other people income is good
for just about everybody so I'm in favor
of doing it I've done no careful
research into the feasibility or the
best way to get there or anything like
that so I think it's a wonderful goal to
have something to work toward I'm not
exactly sure what the best route to
getting there really is Charles Hertz
says suppose that there were a
civilization on another planet whose
Science and Technology were for all
practical purposes identical to ours in
2020 suppose that the inhabitants were
aware through astronomy of the existence
of our earth and for whatever reason set
about to look intensively for science of
intelligent life there can you give me a
ballpark estimate of how far away their
planet could be and still leave them
with a decent chance of success no I
really can't
that sounds like a homework problem that
I would have to sit down and do some
calculations for presumably it could be
done but it depends not only on what we
are beaming out into the universe but
the sensitivity of the radio telescopes
that they would be using to look for us
etc so it's a doable problem but one
that I don't really have the time to sit
down and do i do think that it brings up
this related fact that looking for
intelligent civilizations by scanning
the sky and radio telescopes is
something that I personally think is
incredibly unlikely to ever work because
I think that the chances for another
civilization in our state of
technological capability to be right
there at the right time is extremely low
and once a civilization gets to a higher
level of technological capability they
are not going to wastefully beam out
radio waves into the surrounding space
for no good reason so I think there's
better ways to look for technological
civilizations elsewhere
Patrick Feeney says the controversy
about the Hubble constant being either
sixty nine point seven kilometers per
second per megaparsec versus seventy
three point five rages on given the two
different methods are being used for the
calculation why is it so important that
there's a small discrepancy between them
that is labeled a cosmic crisis so I
talked about this a little bit earlier
on but look I don't label it a comic
cosmic crisis I think there's a certain
amount of marketing that is going on in
labeling it a cosmic crisis it would be
a cosmic opportunity if it were true
because it would be telling us something
really important about the universe but
you know to be
pher let's put it on the other side the
two methods should agree right I mean
just because you use two methods if
you're measuring the same thing and you
believe in an external reality you're
supposed to get the same answer so
either something's really going on or
one of the methods is wrong it's not
that because they're two methods they're
measuring different things so one way or
the other there's something to be
figured out that we haven't quite
figured out yet Michael McCready says I
struggle with the idea that the Big Bang
occurred everywhere and that regardless
of where you find yourself in the
universe you would essentially observe
the same cosmic surroundings why if you
found yourself on the expanding edge of
the universe would you not see an empty
night sky in the direction of that edge
so the answer here is that there's no
such thing as the expanding edge of the
universe
there's the expanding edge of what we
can see from here but if you were there
then what we can see from here would be
irrelevant we would be on the edge as
far as you are concerned and we're not
sure what you would see if you looked on
the other direction but the easiest most
natural most likely thing to imagine is
that it's similar to what we see in the
universe where we do observe in our
current universe in other words that
things are more or less uniform from the
perspective of someone who is far away
ten billion or twenty billion
light-years away just as they are to us
right here right now there's no edge to
the universe there's no sensible
cosmological model in which the universe
has anything like a real edge it could
be infinite or it could be finite
it could be homogeneous and isotropic or
it could be very very different but
there's no reason to think it has an
edge Jose Ignacio of canterra Alcantara
Alcantara yeah says I very much agree
with your approach that if we are to
develop a quantum theory of gravity
makes much more sense to look forward
arising from a quantum origin than a
classical one but to my mind there's a
hiccup what if quantum theory turns out
not to be a fundamental description of
fundamental reality to this end I was
hoping that you might Lisa mole invite
Lee Smolin for one of your podcasts soon
so you know it's always possible the
quantum theory is not a fundamental
description of reality but as I said in
a different context above as a
researcher you have to bet
i as a researcher you can't always say
you know what all of our theories could
be wrong I'm gonna distrust all of them
and try to build up everything from the
ground up that's not really a way to get
ahead usually so I'm glad that some
people are thinking about alternatives
to quantum mechanics but there is
literally zero empirical evidence that
quantum mechanics is not right and there
are plenty of theoretical and
philosophical and practical questions
about quantum mechanics we don't know
the answer to so in my mind the way more
promising way forward is to try to
understand the quantum mechanics we have
rather than to try to throw it out and
replace it with something else
Joshua Hillier up says suppose a big
expensive experiment is done in space
where according to general relativity a
small kugelblitz is made of a size word
should evaporate due to Hawking
radiation in a reasonable time frame to
observe for an experiment a kugelblitz
is an idea like a ball of radiation that
you point into a small enough region to
create a black hole assuming the
experiment was performed correctly and
there are no great advances in quantum
gravity before then would it be
guaranteed to give us useful data or
could it potentially just confirm what
is already known we would certainly like
to see up close the evaporation of a
black hole and its final explosion but
there is no guarantee whatsoever that
would give us useful data so we have a
prediction for what would happen it
would dissolve in a bunch of particles
it might be that more massive particles
than we can create in current particle
accelerators would be made but they
would be expected to very rapidly decay
into other particles so the whole point
of Hawking's calculation is that what do
you expect to see coming out of a black
hole is thermal radiation radiation
which has a more or less featureless
blackbody spectrum the one example the
one counter example of this is if there
are particles at very high energies very
high masses which are stable or quasi
stable or long-lived enough that we
could actually observe them that would
be wonderful new data if there was
something about quantum gravity that
deviated from Hawking's calculation of
course that would be wonderful wonderful
new data but there's absolutely no
guarantee that we
learn anything new there very rarely are
guarantees when you do physics
experiments anton grace says I would
like to ask you if there if you were
always this open-minded or if you had a
different mentality in regards to the
usefulness and purpose of philosophy in
the past and if so what changed you I
don't think I was ever of the opinion
that philosophy was useless I just
didn't know or think that much about
philosophy when I was in high school
when I was an undergraduate and started
to study it I instantly thought it was
fascinating and potentially important I
went through a phase where I was one of
these people who thought that all of the
interesting questions of philosophy
could sort of be tackled scientifically
right like right and wrong could be
decided on purely rational empirical
scientific basis and I changed my mind
about that I'm much more subjective
about the notions of morality and ethics
now than I used to be
Riverside says would you agree that we
are morally obliged to take preventative
measures available to us in our present
time to help avert or mitigate the
terrible crimes that our future selves
persons branching out of us at each
decoherence event will commit against
the future cells of our loved ones in
some of the branching pads of the
many-worlds universe so there's a couple
of reasons that the answer here is no
one is of course the notion of moral
obligation is a little fuzzy and I
generally don't like to use that notion
in contentious issues I mean wait use it
casually when we all agree on what the
morality is so in tricky questions I
like to be a little bit more careful
than that but more importantly as I've
already discussed earlier in the AMA I
think that the moral implications of
many worlds are exactly the same as the
moral implications of a version of
quantum mechanics which was truly
stochastic in which there was only one
world but you just couldn't predict what
would happen I think that there are
unlikely things that will happen and
there are likely things that would
happen and we should adjust our actions
accordingly I don't think that many
worlds has any moral implications aside
from regular quantum mechanics
whatsoever P Walter says in the recent
episode of the Infinite Monkey cage you
indicated that the many-worlds
interpretation naturally
comes out of the equations of quantum
mechanics Jim Jim al-khalili in the same
episode indicated the many-worlds view
is not implied in the fundamental
equations can you clarify for me whether
it is or is not I so it depends on what
you mean okay I hate to be weaselly
about that but gotta be honest the
equations of many worlds are just the
Schrodinger equation and the
wavefunction evolving that's the
fundamental definition of the theory
unlike other versions of quantum
mechanics were unlike classical
mechanics or something like that
the tricky part of many worlds is
explaining why that Theory accounts for
the world we see okay
quantum mechanics you know when we teach
it in schools that's when we use words
like measurement and observation right
there in the theory so explaining the
outcomes of measurement or observations
is not hard because it's baked in to
their rules in many worlds there are no
words about measurements or observations
there aren't even words about worlds or
branching or decoherence those are all
extra words that we human beings use as
an convenient emergent way of talking
about the wave function of the universe
so that's why there can be this
disagreement about whether or not the
many worlds theory comes out of the
equations the theories equations are
just the equations there's no extra
equations no extra ingredients put on
there but there is extra philosophical
work to be done to explain why that
theory predicts the world that we see
someone like me and many of the other
people who thought about this say well
yes it clearly does there's clearly
different parts of the wavefunction that
don't interact and describe separate
worlds etc others do not see it that way
Judith Marsh says whenever I see
illustrations of black holes they're
always drawn like a whirlpool or funnel
with things falling in the hole from the
top you can't approach it from the
bottom what a real black holes entire
spherical surface send matter towards
its center in all three dimensions do
black holes have an equator so I presume
what you're thinking about are these
sort of funnel like diagrams where you
see curved space-time and you
sort of go down into the funnel you know
let's be honest
these are picturesque representations
that are trying to help you visualize
something and they're not very accurate
for one thing they're not very accurate
because black holes are regions have
warped space-time not just warped space
there's no up or down in space-time but
there is the future and the point of a
black hole is once you enter the event
horizon in the future of yourself you
will eventually hit the singularity so
do black holes have an equator you know
it depends on whether the black hole is
spinning or not the black hole can be
spinning in which case it absolutely has
an axis and an equator a non spinning
black hole is perfectly spherically
symmetric so there's no difference in
whatever direction you actually travel
into it
Sam Hartzog says my question is about
gravity the maxim for general relativity
goes space tells matter how to move
matter tells space how to curve so is it
more correct to imagine the force of
gravity is acting on space-time itself
with the apparent action on matter being
a byproduct of the spatial curvature
imparted by gravity I was thinking about
graviton so my mind went down this
rabbit hole so if you could give a
little context on how gravitons by plane
to the answer I give you 50 bonus points
so you know the it's actually a slightly
trickier question then you might even
think because when we teach general
relativity like if you buy my general
relativity book and learn it from there
what you'll be taught is the following
that you solve n steins equations
Einstein's equations give you a
consistent simultaneous description of
the energy generated by matter what's
called the energy momentum tensor and
the curvature of space-time it sets them
equal to each other but the geometry of
space-time is described by what we
called the metric which tells you how
space-time curves is involved in both of
those parts it's involved in both the
curvature of space-time obviously but
also in the distribution of matter and
energy through the universe so you have
to look for a simultaneous solution all
at once and then once you do that once
you find a solution to the geometry of
space-time when you talk about you know
how a planet goes around this
or how a ray of light is deflected by
the curvature of space-time you idealize
the planet or the photon as having no
gravitational field itself that's a
little bit of an idealization right
you're asking how a test particle would
move through a curved space-time that it
wasn't itself affecting but in the real
world everything that has any energy
whatsoever is going to both affect and
be affected by the curvature of
space-time around it so it's it's not
really that gravity is acting on
space-time I mean gravity is a feature
of space-time but that feature is not
separate from what the matter is doing
you have to sort of solve for both
simultaneously at the same time
gravitons play into the answer not at
all unless you imagine quantizing
gravity and then it's exactly like
electromagnetism and photons right you
can talk about a classical electric
field or magnetic field or you could
talk about them in photons and there's a
translation between the two but if
they're big in classical fields there's
no reason to talk about photons likewise
for big classical gravitational fields
there's no reason to talk about
gravitons Fred Alexander says Scott
Aaronson stated in the Lex Friedman
podcast that the greatest use of quantum
computing will be studying quantum
systems thereby learning more about
quantum mechanics do you agree and if so
how and what might we learn so I not
sure what the greatest use of quantum
mechanics is going to be studying
quantum systems is absolutely one of the
most obvious things you can do it was
the original motivation for people like
Fineman in the early years of quantum
computing so clearly a quantum computer
is going to have an easier time
simulating and therefore analyzing
quantum systems than a classical
computer we'll just because of
computational capacity but I don't know
whether that's going to be the killer
app or not I can imagine there's other
apps that I haven't thought of yet what
are we going to learn about quantum
mechanics you know I don't think we will
learn anything about the foundations of
quantum mechanics because I think the
foundations of quantum mechanics are
pretty much in place I think what we'll
learn is how the foundations play out
how the actual quantum interacts
actions and entanglement and things like
that arise and affect things in the real
world where things are too hard to
simulate on a classical computer so
we'll learn a lot about chemistry for
example you know chemistry at heart is
all quantum mechanics right how
different atoms trade electrons back and
forth and so forth that's all quantum
mechanics and we're not very good at
approximating it that's why chemists
have a job and you know mix chemicals in
their labs we can't really simulate it
for any interestingly complex systems so
I think that we'll learn about how
quantum mechanics manifests in the world
not about what the fundamental rules of
quantum mechanics are Alan Petersen says
a simple clarification question how has
the expansion of the universe changed
over time did it start fast with
inflation slowed down and now accelerate
so this is a good question actually
because it's tricky what do you mean by
the expansion of the universe here's how
I would put it the sensible way to
quantify the expansion rate of the
universe is through the Hubble parameter
right we hold the Hubble constant but of
course it changes over time and if you
do it that way the Hubble parameter only
ever decreases throughout the history of
the universe as the universe expands the
Hubble parameter depends on the energy
density and the energy density ever only
goes down until the cosmological
constant kicks in and it begins to
asymptote to a constant so when we say
the universe is accelerating
we don't really mean the expansion rate
is speeding up in particular the Hubble
constant is not speeding up during the
expansion rate of the during the
accelerating phase of the universe's
history rather what happens is
individual galaxies for which you say
the velocity that you observe is their
distance times the Hubble constant that
goes up with time because the Hubble
constant becomes constant and their
distance increases so the apparent
velocity goes up if V equals H times D
velocity is Hubble constant times
distance in the ordinary way of thinking
about things the distance is increasing
but the Hubble constant is decreasing
even faster so the galaxy looks
it's decelerating away but when the
Hubble constant approaches a constant
the increasing distance leads to an
increasing velocity and that's what we
characterize as the acceleration of the
universe it doesn't mean the expansion
rate is going up Nico's thug soccer
raucous sorry I'm just having a bad day
today with the pronunciation of the
names I do apologize for that but he
says Nico's is nice enough to say do not
worry if you cannot pronounce my name
just called me soccer all right sagar
says the thought is the following what
Allah places demon need to be conscious
at all though Posse and demon I'm
talking about would not be result of
evolution but be an agent that was from
the beginning on that level of
computational capacity so again I think
it depends on how what do you really
mean by laplace's demon so I could
imagine a version of Laplace this demon
that was conscious or one that was not
conscious so think of it this way you
know we think that our universe is big
and there's all these particles in it
and so forth but what if we really do
live in a simulation what if we live in
a simulation where the creatures that
are simulating us are just enormous ly
bigger and better than us in
calculational capacity and power so much
so that to them looking at literally
everything in our observable universe is
equivalent to us looking at a
tic-tac-toe board okay it might be hard
to imagine that but you can in principle
imagine is just a scaling right so to
them they're perfectly conscious and for
as far as we're concerned they're
Laplace is demon right like most of us
don't have trouble imagining where the
tic-tac-toe game is going to go soon
especially if it were deterministic
automaton rather than a game played by
oppositional antagonistic opponents so I
can imagine a version of lipolysis demon
that was perfectly conscious on the
other hand I can also imagine a very
minimal one one that was more of like
just a computer right just at like a
computer that was simulating our
universe with perfect fidelity that kind
of lipolysis demon wouldn't need to be
conscious at all so I think that the
original thought experiment from Laplace
just doesn't determine the answer to
these questions but you're you're very
open very willing very able to think of
different versions of it
Braham Blanc says I know that you know
that evolution is a thing and you've
talked about the continuing evolution of
the human race and some of your podcasts
I've always felt that we are actually D
evolving as a race due to medical
science as well as societal pressures
making it possible for people to survive
who would not have survived in the
totally natural environment like the
environment where humans first evolved
do you think we are de evolving or
they're offsetting pressures causing
further evolution in a positive way I
think I would just uh nask this question
or at least I would deny the premises
behind it there's I think there's no
such thing as de evolution I think that
what seems to be implicit in the
question you're asking is the idea that
evolution natural selection right and
the Darwinian sense is somehow
progressive it somehow makes us more and
more powerful or intelligent or
complicated or something like that but
there is absolutely nothing like that
inherent in evolution evolution is not a
story of progress it's just a story of
adaptation to a changing environment and
it's you know slow and there's a lot of
randomness in it but certainly in
evolution all over the place there's the
there are examples of capacities that
species had being lost over time right
there are species that used to have eyes
that then burped on the ground and lost
the ability to see for example it's
still evolution it's not de evolution in
any way their circumstance has changed
therefore what kind of animal they were
also changed so I do think that
evolution continues on like it or not
you know we can tinker with our
environment we can even tinker with our
genome at this point in time but is
still true that sexual reproduction and
mutation is going to lead to a slight
set of changes in our genome over time
and they will be selected for the
pressures that select for different
traits might be completely different in
our current environment than they were
ten thousand or a hundred thousand or a
million years ago but there still are
pressures certain kind of genomes are
going to give rise to more offspring
than other kinds that's just not going
to stop happening
gabor Peter says er says it was good to
see you in your office in the video of
veritasium YouTube channel so for those
of you who don't know I recently
appeared in a video on veritasium where
Derek Muller is trying to explain the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics especially using the double
slit and other and Schrodinger's cat and
other classic experiments so the
question is I saw there were some
bottles on the shelves have you tasted
any Hungarian wine I recommend you the
best sweet dessert wine of the world
it's Takashi a shoe so I have tasted
Takashi I'm a fan I'm not a huge fan of
dessert wines I don't do them very often
more of a whiskey person if I'm gonna
have anything at all after the wine
drinking portion of the meal has ended
but I have had it it's good I agree I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna agree that it's
the best in the world because I had no
opinion on that I will not take sides on
that issue for those of you who are
wondering the bottles on the shelves in
my office are champagne bottles and
they're all empty there's one bottle for
every PhD student I've had who has
successfully defended their thesis I
think I'm up to 13 bottles right now but
it might it might be 14 I might be
missing count okay the last question is
Ross Hastings says my question this
month relates to Donald Hoffman's
fitness beats truth theorem and his
claim that our perceptions of objective
reality including space-time are a mere
desktop interface hiding a fundamentally
different world altogether
what credence would you assign to the
fitness beats truth the theorem so I
think you know I'm not that interested
in this I get a lot of questions about
it I don't think that there's a lot
interesting going on here there's a
sense in which it is trivially true and
there's a sense in which I think it is
deeply false the sense in which I think
it's trivially true is that of course
our everyday picture of the world that
we see with our eyeballs in touch with
our hands doesn't give us very direct
access access to the true nature of
reality right I think we all know that
if you think the true nature of reality
for example is a quantum wavefunction
obeying the Schrodinger equation I don't
see the wavefunction with my eyes it's
taken hundreds of years of science to
figure that out so we have other
theories like Newtonian classical
physics or for that matter Aristotelian
physics
that are much more natural direct
immediate models of the world around us
so in that sense our perceptions are
much closer to Aristotelian physics than
they are to quantum mechanics and
therefore our perceptions are not giving
us the entire truth I think that's kind
of obviously true and I'm not surprised
by that but the idea that we somehow
can't get to the fundamental reality
underneath it all or the idea that there
isn't any fundamental reality or the
idea that we are creating a fundamental
reality or the idea that different
people have different versions of
fundamental reality there is no
fundamental reality I don't like any of
those ideas at all I think there is a
fundamental reality I think we're
getting closer and closer to it I think
the process by which we get closer and
closer to it is called science this is
what I do for a living I think that you
know there's an there's a school of
thought which I think that Hoffman is
sympathetic to although I don't know
whether he would characterize himself
this way but there's been a school of
thought for hundreds of years that puts
mental action at the center of things
and physical reality as a subsidiary or
secondary thing right there's different
being intentionally vague because
there's different variations on this
theme but idealism and other theories
that put mind at the center and physical
reality secondary and I am entirely on
the other side of that I think that
physical reality comes first mind and
cognition and thinking and perception
and so forth these are all just ways of
talking about certain aspects of
objective physical reality and if you
want more on that you can buy my book
the big picture I'm very glad that I've
written all these books now so I can
actually tell people to go read them
when these questions come up but ok
that's it for this month thanks very
much for listening in and those of you
who are here first because you're not
patreon supporters I hope you enjoyed it
I hope you got something out of it come
back next month when we'll have another
exciting bout of questions here on
mindscape AMA
[Music]
you
[Music]